pour ce qui concerne mon frère nous ne
savons pas où est ce qu'ils se trouvent
actuellement ne savons pas avec les
tensions qui vient
s'ils osent se rendront pas à la justice
mais il faut savoir que il a grandi ici
il a étudié ici d'un garçon tout à fait
normal vous venez d'entendre le frère
d'un des kamikazes qui s'est fait sauter
le frère d'un autre qui est activement
recherché sur la planète s'appelle salah
abdel sam lui qui celui qui parlait
c'était mohamed adel sam bruxelles donc
dans un quartier où ses trois frères ont
grandi mathieu prost
résultat on a on connaît maintenant cinq
des huit terroristes 5 avec avec
certitude effectivement patrice et pour
bien savoir qui ils sont et quel est
leur profil
il faut un peu les catégoriser en
fonction des équipes auxquelles ils ont
participé il y avait trois équipes
pendant cette soirée meurtrière la
première c'est l'équipe du stade de
france au nord de paris donc 3 trois
terroristes ici le premier c'est bilal a
défini un français de 20 ans un français
qui était connu des services de
renseignement qui avait séjourné en
syrie entre 2013 et 2014 le deuxième
c'est un homme dont le passeport c'est
celui dont on a retrouvé un passeport
sport c'est un bon passeport sur ce
passeport il est marqué ahmed nous
ramène des réfugiés d'un réfugié cette
information cette identité est encore à
confirmer
est-ce que l'homme correspond bien à
celui qui était sur le passeport le
passeport et peut être volé en tout cas
ils étaient enregistrées en grèce et in
on a retrouvé ce passeport avec ce nom
dessus le troisième terroriste du stade
de france qui s'est fait exploser on ne
connaît pas son identité
la deuxième équipe et bien c'est
l'équipe du bataclan là où il ya eu 89
morts
là aussi trois hommes le premier ismail
omar mostefaoui c'est lui qui était le
premier identifié un français aussi de
29 ans il était il a été aussi séjourné
en syrie le deuxième set oms a mis i'm
in our 28 ans jeunes aussi qui était
connu et qui était sous contrôle
judiciaire depuis
1010 mais il avait échappé à son
contrôle judiciaire et il était
recherché depuis lors le troisième est
aussi inconnu
et enfin la dernière équipe c'est celle
qui a mitraillé sur les barres des
terrasses dans les 10e et 11e
arrondissements deux hommes ici
identifié brahim des slams vous en
parliez c'est celui qui s'est fait
exploser et son frère donc activement
recherché salade et slam qui a été
contrôlé par la police dans le nord de
la france entre paris et bruxelles mais
n'y avait pas d' avis de recherche avait
été lancé à ce moment là il n'a donc pas
été un arrêté paul lors de ce contrôle
mais maintenant on a lancé un appel à
témoins pour pouvoir leur trouver donc
trois frères dont celui qu'on a entendu
qui lui dit je ne savais rien un qui
s'est fait sauter et celui là qu'on
recherche partout sur la planète et
celui la nounou points est en direction
de présumément le cerveau de l'opération
qui est qu'à ces journées déjà bruxelles
mais qui sera un cyril exactement il
s'appelle il s'appelle cet homme à d'el
hamid about et salades et slam a fait de
la prison avec lui c'est pour ça qu'ils
se connaissaient et oui il est considéré
comme le cerveau présumé des attentats
de paris
il serait probablement en syrie ou en
irak
à l'heure où on se parle c'est un belge
de 29 ans donc après la mise à bas ou d'
qui est dit-on en contact direct avec
aboubakeur al bagdadi le chef de l'état
islamique et les enquêteurs pensent
effectivement que c'est bien que ça vaut
présumé parce que via notamment un
témoignage recueilli par les enquêteurs
français
il y à trois mois d'un djihadiste
français qui revenaient de syrie il a
parlé un d'abdelhamid abou oud
cet homme lui aurait dit de commettre un
attentat notamment dans une salle de
concert et il y a des liens entre cet
homme et deux récentes affaires vous
rappelez sûrement pas tristes la sphère
du thalys son nom est cité dans cette
affaire là donc stern attentat raté
celui ci un autre attentat raté c'était
l'église de villejuif
en france son nom apparaît dans ce
dossier la hausse et douma tués ont
conclu là-dessus 12 cette déclaration de
françois hollande aujourd'hui qui a dit
ces attentats ont été imaginés dirigé de
la syrie organisée de la belgique avec
les complicités intérieur en france en
france et perpétrer bien sûr en france
merci très clair mathieu très bien